En algunos casos, por inoperancia
o por falta de ética,
pero casi siempre es porque nos han guiado hacia objetivos equivocados.
Y eso es inadmisible.
Hay que terminar con esto.
¿Cómo vamos a corregir estos errores?
¿Cómo podremos elegir el camino correcto?
No será fácil.
Trabajo desde hace años con equipos excelentes
que han elegido objetivos acertados y desacertados.
Muchos tuvieron éxito, otros fracasaron.
Hoy les hablaré
de lo que realmente hace la diferencia,
de lo crucial,
de cómo y por qué
sus objetivos son valederos y audaces;
fijan los objetivos correctos por las razones correctas.
Remontémonos al año 1975.
Este soy yo.
Tengo mucho por aprender, soy ingeniero en computación,
llevo el pelo largo,
y trabajo con Andy Grove,
considerado el mejor gerente de su época o de cualquier otra.
Andy fue un líder excelente y también un gran maestro,
y me dijo: "John, en realidad no interesa lo que sabes.
Lo que más importa es lo que haces".
Andy inventó un sistema llamado "Objetivos y resultados clave".
Suena bien, ¿verdad?
Se refiere a hacer las cosas bien.
Veremos ahora un clásico video de la década de 1970
del profesor Andy Grove.
(Video) Andy Grove: Las dos frases clave en la gerencia por sistemas de metas
son los objetivos y los resultados clave, que combinan los dos propósitos.
El objetivo es la dirección.
Los resultados clave deben medirse,
pero al final, sin ningún tipo de argumento, uno puede decir:
"¿Lo logré o no lo logré?". Sí. No. Simple.
John Doerr: Ese es Andy.
Sí. No. Simple.
Objetivos y resultados clave,
u ORC,
son un sistema sencillo para establecer objetivos
y funciona para organizaciones, para equipos,
y también para individuos.
Los objetivos son lo que queremos lograr.
Los resultados clave se refieren a la manera en que lo lograremos.
Objetivos. Resultados clave.
Qué y cómo.
Pero la verdad es esta:
muchos nos trazamos objetivos equivocados,
y la mayoría ni siquiera nos fijamos un objetivo.
Muchas organizaciones establecen sus objetivos y los cumplen.
Venden su mercadería, introducen sus nuevos productos,
hacen sus números,
pero no saben fijar metas para motivar a sus equipos.
¿Cómo trazar estos objetivos de la manera correcta, entonces?
Primero, hay que responder a la pregunta "¿por qué?".
¿Por qué?
Porque los equipos realmente transformadores
combinan sus ambiciones con la pasión y con el propósito,
y así desarrollan un sentido claro y contundente del porqué.
Les contaré una historia.
Trabajo con una emprendedora increíble.
Se llama Jini Kim.
Maneja una empresa llamada Nuna.
Nuna es una compañía de datos sobre la salud de los individuos.
Cuando la empresa se fundó,
usaron datos para atender las necesidades de muchos empleados de grandes empresas.
Luego de dos años de experiencia en la vida de la empresa,
el gobierno federal lanzó la propuesta
para desarrollar la primera base de datos de Medicaid en la nube.
Recordemos que Medicaid es un programa
que asiste a 70 millones de estadounidenses,
a los pobres, a los niños
y a personas con discapacidad.
En aquella época, Nuna contaba tan solo con 15 empleados
y esta base de datos debía ser desarrollada en un año,
y tenían además una serie de compromisos que cumplir
y, en verdad, no iban a hacer mucho dinero con el proyecto.
Este era el momento de asumir el riesgo,
y Jini lo hizo.
Aprovechó la oportunidad. No la dejó pasar.
¿Por qué?
Pues bien, el motivo es personal.
Kimong, el hermano menor de Jini, tiene autismo.
A los siete años, tuvo su primera crisis de epilepsia, en Disneylandia.
Cayó al suelo. Su respiración se detuvo.
Los padres de Jini son inmigrantes coreanos.
Llegaron al país con muy pocos recursos,
con escaso dominio del inglés,
de manera que fue responsabilidad de Jini afiliar a su familia a Medicaid.
Tenía nueve años.
Ese momento definió su misión,
y esa misión se transformó en su empresa,
y esa empresa se presentó, ganó la licitación y cumplió con ese contrato.
En este video, Jini explica por qué.
(Video) Jini Kim: Medicaid salvó a mi familia de la quiebra,
y actualmente se ocupa de la salud de Kimong y de millones de personas.
Nuna es mi carta de amor a Medicaid.
Cada hilera de datos es una vida
cuya historia merece ser contada con dignidad.
JD: Y la historia de Jini nos enseña
que un motivo valedero puede ser el punto de partida de nuestras metas.
Recordemos que eso es lo que queremos lograr.
Y los objetivos tienen sentido,
están orientados hacia la acción,
son inspiradores,
y son como una vacuna contra los pensamientos confusos.
Podría decirse que una estrella de rock
no sería precisamente un usuario de los objetivos y resultados clave
pero, desde hace años, Bono aplica este sistema de ORC
para combatir la pobreza y la enfermedad en todo el mundo.
Su organización "ONE" gira en torno a dos objetivos
realmente maravillosos, audaces.
El primero es la condonación de la deuda
de los países más pobres del mundo.
El otro es el acceso universal a los remedios para curar el VIH.
Ahora bien, ¿por qué son buenos estos objetivos?
Repasemos la lista anterior.
¿Tienen sentido? Sí. ¿Son concretos? Sí.
¿Están orientados a la acción? Sí.
¿Son inspiradores?
Escuchemos ahora a Bono.
(Video) Bono: ¿Eres apasionado?
¿Cuán apasionado?
¿Qué acciones son manejadas por tu pasión?
Si tu corazón no está en perfecta sintonía con tu cabeza,
entonces tu pasión no significa nada.
El sistema de ORC cultiva la locura,
la química que tiene adentro.
Nos da el marco para el riesgo,
la confianza,
donde el fracaso no es motivo de despido.
Y cuando tenemos ese tipo de estructura y de contexto,
y la gente adecuada,
la magia está a la vuelta de la esquina.
JD: Me encanta esa parte:
OCR cultiva la locura
y la magia está a la vuelta de la esquina.
Es perfecto.
Entonces, con Jini hemos visto el porqué,
con Bono el qué de la fijación de objetivos.
Veamos ahora el cómo.
Recordemos que el cómo son los resultados clave,
es decir, cómo logramos nuestros objetivos.
Y los buenos resultados son específicos y de tiempo limitado.
Son agresivos pero realistas.
Son mensurables y verificables.
Estos son buenos resultados clave.
En 1999, introduje la técnica de ORC a los cofundadores de Google,
Larry y Sergey.
Allí están, 24 años, en su garaje.
Sergey dijo con entusiasmo que adoptaría este sistema.
Pero, en verdad, no fue tan así.
Lo que dijo en realidad fue:
"No tenemos otra manera de manejar la empresa,
así que haremos la prueba".
(Risas)
Y lo tomé como una especie de respaldo.
Desde entonces, cada trimestre,
cada empleado de Google registra sus objetivos y sus resultados.
Los clasifican y los publican para que todos los vean.
Y estos datos no se usan para bonificaciones ni ascensos.
Se los reserva. Se los usa para propósitos más elevados,
es decir, para hacer que el compromiso colectivo
realmente expanda los objetivos.
En 2008, un empleado de Google, Sundar Pichai, asumió un objetivo:
construir una plataforma de próxima generación para el cliente
para el futuro de las aplicaciones web.
En otras palabras, desarrollar el mejor navegador.
Pensó muy bien cómo elegir sus resultados clave.
¿Cómo se mide el mejor navegador?
Quizá por los clics en los anuncios o el nivel de fidelidad.
No. Él decía: "Cantidad de usuarios",
porque son ellos los que van a decidir
si Chrome es un buen navegador o no.
De modo que Pichai tenía que cumplir este objetivo en tres años:
desarrollar el mejor navegador.
Y cada año se aferraba a los mismos resultados clave: la cantidad de usuarios.
Pero subió la apuesta.
El primer año, su meta fue llegar a 20 millones de usuarios, y no pudo.
Logró menos de 10.
El segundo año, elevó la expectativa a 50 millones,
y llegó a los 37 millones de usuarios.
Un poco mejor.
El tercer año,
volvió a subir la apuesta y alcanzó los 100 millones.
Lanzó una agresiva campaña de 'marketing',
amplió la distribución, mejoró la tecnología... y ¡bum!
Llegó a los 111 millones de usuarios.
Por eso me gusta esta historia.
No tanto por el final feliz,
sino porque muestra a alguien que eligió el objetivo correcto con mucho cuidado
y se aferró a él año tras año, tras año.
Es una historia perfecta para un empollón como yo.
Ahora bien, los ORC son, para mí, como recipientes transparentes
hechos con el qué y el cómo de nuestras ambiciones.
Lo que realmente importa es el porqué con que llenamos esos recipientes.
Ese el motivo por el cual hacemos un trabajo.
Los OCR no son ninguna solución milagrosa.
No reemplazarán una cultura sólida
ni un liderazgo más fuerte,
pero cuando esas reglas básicas están en su lugar, nos pueden llevar a la cima.
Quiero que piensen en sus vidas por un momento.
¿Hacen las mediciones correctas?
Tómense el tiempo para escribir sus valores,
sus objetivos y resultados clave.
Háganlo hoy mismo.
Si quieren que les dé mi opinión, me los pueden enviar
a john@whatmatters.com.
Si pensamos en las metas que han cambiado el mundo
como Intel, Nuna, Bono, Google,
son metas fuera de serie:
informática al alcance de todos,
atención sanitaria asequible y de primera calidad para todos,
erradicación de la pobreza en el mundo,
acceso a toda la información que hay en el mundo.
Y esta es la esencia:
cada una de esas metas se rige actualmente por los ORC.
Me han llamado el "Juanito Manzanas" de los ORC
por difundir la verdad según Andy Grove,
pero quiero que Uds. me acompañen en este movimiento.
Luchemos por lo que realmente importa.
Porque podemos aplicar los ORC fuera de nuestro trabajo,
los podemos aplicar en la familia,
en la escuela,
incluso en nuestros gobiernos.
Podemos exigirle responsabilidad a esos gobiernos.
Podemos transformar esas informaciones.
Podemos retomar el camino correcto
si logramos medir lo que realmente importa.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)